trump is hungry to go head-to-head
against biden for president
and can only be stopped by a
prison sentence says former adviser the
signs that he uh is increasingly
interested says david gergen a political
commentator and former white house
communications director served under
various administrations his interest
intensifies when he sees biden in
trouble when biden for example receives
backlash for his decision to withdraw
all u.s troops from afghanistan
prompting a swift taliban takeover trump
was really chomping at the bit gurgan
said three sources said that the former
president trump came close to announcing
the 2024 run in august at the height of
the chaos in afghanistan advisers
stepped in and convinced him not to do
it
due to a fear that his announcement
would derail the republican attempt to
take back congress in upcoming 2022
midterm elections wow
wow what a story right there too to
think that by the way trump had a pretty
good week with his spac when he
introduced the truth
the social media site that's coming out
he made very very good money last week
uh with the spec and it's not slowing
down but going back to the store you're
talking about he can't wait to get in
the rink trump just cannot wait to get
back and he just doesn't want to say it
he's holding back saying we'll see if
i'm gonna run we'll see if i'm gonna run
folks if you're listening to this i'm
just curious i'm watching the comments
if you would if you would rather have
trump run on the republican side
type in the word trump if it's desantis
type in desantis i'm just
curious between the two can you do a
poll in there or no
does the chat box allows you to do a
pull
all right then if you can do a pull do a
poll
i don't know if you can do a poll but
i'll leave it up to you
um so what do you think about this uh
story with uh trump and um
gurgan saying the fact that they
prevented him from saying that because
they didn't want the midterms to be
affected by this who prevented him from
saying that okay so the three sources
said that the former president came
close announcing the 2024 run in august
at the height of the chaos in
afghanistan an advisor stepped in and
convinced him not to due to a fear that
his announcement would derail the
republican attempt to take back congress
in upcoming 2022 midterm elections yeah
they're basically saying don
don't do anything to screw up that there
are inevitable
taking over of the house
you know what that means though that
means he's listening to people which is
new
i mean i literally wrote
he's listening to people mr adam he's
listening to your advice i think he is
chomping at the bit to get back out
there he sees uh blood in the water i
have a question joe biden sinking in the
approval ratings and he wants to get
back out there but there's no question
announcing anything until after the
midterms
will they run joe biden again
i don't think they would that's the
question is who runs against trump so
there's there's three questions right
because to pick it back real quick
before this what was the last president
to be in office and not run for
re-election when they could
there's from
what i looked at this morning there's
one president in the line of 46
presidents that has not run for
re-election there's a handful of them
that haven't won but there's one
president who just flat out said yeah
not for me who's that
and he goes on hold on hold on hold on
here it's lbg yeah yeah you could just
said it you just before i even saw it i
was like it's got to be lb is it lbj
yeah
he's the only president but he he was
there for six years because he took over
for jfk for two years okay yeah ran for
re-election and then after that he said
yeah this is not for me he said they
were pulling out of vietnam and they
were um they were that he wouldn't run
for re-election i just i think
i hope that joe biden doesn't run again
in 2024. i hope he does a good job i
hope he leaves the country the right way
the next few years he's obviously not
doing the best job ever
we need some new blood in there if i
were to make enough with the old
freaking idiots if i were to make a
prediction i think joe biden might be
the only
democrat that can't beat
trump
but he already knew kamala harris could
not again again by running again
the only democrat that can't i think i
think if if it's a joe biden versus a
trump yeah
then there's odds that he can't i think
if there's a new person coming in well
so here's my question where are we at in
four years or three and a half years
we've already got inflation we're only
nine months through this term ten months
through this term we've got inflation is
high they're pushing through the two and
a half trillion dollar bill they're the
two trillion dollar building that's true
iran can't win china's saber lab
rattling iran russia i mean where are we
at in four years
that's going to determine as much as we
want to look into our crystal ball i
mean whatever we could say anything
right now and it's like zero relevance
the reality is we've got to get through
midterms and then the election the
the what people are failing to
understand is you know how hard the
media railed against trump when he ran
the first time and when he ran against
this time
now you don't think they're going to
take the january sixth insurrection
wherever you want to call it and play
that non-stop and you don't think the
ads
yeah they've already done that for me
okay but now when he's running for a
re-election you don't think there's an
ad that's just gonna show everything and
say
is this what you want from your leader
you don't know how easy it is but people
already know what they're getting with
trump that's the thing they know who he
elected last is exactly they already
know what they're getting
for the millionth time can we get some
freaking young though
give a name on the left freaking the
rock
the rock dulce gabbard and the rock i'd
vote for that ticket yeah seriously
finish the podcast right now we're done
joe manchin thanks for joining us he's
all over the news he's 74. yeah i want
fresh blood
[Laughter]
i don't know i think i think we have we
have time over the next few years to see
what leaders show up i want to make sure
was ron desantis on anybody's list 18
months ago no
but leaders show up in a time of crisis
so who's going to step up from the
democratic party we're seeing people
like desantis show up you'll see who's
gonna show hopefully it's not someone
sure you say your name though say your
name like a newsome like a superstar
like newsome for you well news no
someone
if manchin was younger he's the kind of
guy pete buddhich no not prickly pete
um what if it's not the democratic party
rivero does have support i'm not saying
i'm a big better guy but he's young he's
well spoken he's from texas i know he's
not a big second amendment guy
but someone like a better dirt
better who eats dirt
is that yeah he eat he ate ceremonial
arizona dirt all right that's my kind of
guy kind of man right there i eat taco
bell same [ __ ] so what if it's not what
if it's not the german the democrats so
everybody knows listeners needs to know
this this is not sponsored by taco bell
i just want to know this is just he's
sure maybe you got a side view yeah he
has one we don't know about chalupas
1.99 coming to the corner
i just want to say there's a new grand
slam burrito
anyways
do you not agree we need like
take off your your your republican hat
democratic hat just put on just your
american hat don't you think it's time
for some fresh blood into politics at
the head of tickets
78 year old biden 75 year old trump like
don't you think we got
some young 40 50 year olds well you got
40 and ron desantis okay and anyone
younger on the left like everyone just
sees as communist
socialists so no four i mean how old was
clinton when he got uh elected about the
same time 40s that's what we needed
you're looking for that's what we i'm
looking for a young fresh someone obama
was young clinton was young you know
those two were young
uh reagan was at the time the oldest
president yep uh uh
we had who got reelected yeah so you
know
uh but but also at the same time you
can't force superstars man they got to
come up like this dnc that they need a
convention to have a obama come up and
rise up and give a message to people
like who is this guy right
they thought that the brothers from san
antonio the guy from san antonio but
they they lost the momentum
uh uh you know what i'm talking about
very well spoken you know but you know
they didn't get any support it wasn't
like anything crazy that happened with
them
uh you know who do you have on the left
right now though actually remember who
was on the left when they were running
you don't have a great bullpen i mean
you had amy klobuchar up there that's
not happening right you had beto that's
not happening lizzie warren you had
elizabeth warren that's not happening
obviously you had kamala that's not
happening you had bernie that's done
don't forget about andrew yeah
started his own party
right and joe manchin's talking about
leaving the democratic party to go to
his own article pull up the joe manchin
article i i think we're at a tipping
point where you could see a real change
in american politics because people
don't understand how divided they are
you could see a change from you know you
know what i would want
whoever's elected whoever it is i would
love to have a president who has 60
approval rating
60 percent who's the last president that
had 60 approval rate bill clinton george
w bush okay not that he was a you know
great
didn't turn out but 911 had a lot to do
with him well no when he came in when he
came into office it was
but that's what our country is lacking
there's a majority saying all right
just gave 50 and said the media creates
the problem stress anxiety anger and
fear with trump it's not trump okay
that's steve let's take a look at this
so this is what story this is a uh
intelligencer story is mansion
considering quitting the democratic
party go a little lower as the drama
with intrademocratic negotiations over
the build back better budget
reconciliation intensifies even more
report involving one of the story
central figures and abound to get a lot
of attention veteran mother jones
reported reporter david corn is hearing
talk from joe manchin's associates that
he is mulling a party switch which he
will execute if and when he becomes
definitely dissatisfied
with his influence influence over his
fellow democrats the report was very
specific he told associates that he has
a two-step plan for exist exiting the
party first he would send a letter to
senator chuck schumer the top senate
democrat removing himself from the
democratic leadership of the senate he
is vice chair of the senate democrat
policy and communications committee
manchin hopes that would send a signal
he would then wait and see if that move
had any impact on the negotiations
after about a week he said he would
change his voter registration from
democrat to independence right by the
way when was this story this was a week
ago this was literally last week and
then manu rogers says what uh mansion
deny story he's considering leaving the
democratic party it's [ __ ] he told
me yeah he added i have no control over
rumors and then kelly uh ferris said
knew joe manchin on if he ever planned
to switch parties tells me he made an
offer to switch to independent if him
being a moderate centrist was causing
the damn party and the issue says he
would have still caucus with them's
mansion says that offer was not accepted
interesting and let me ask you yeah
where was joe manchin this weekend
was he at miami with you he wasn't i
wish he was in the club with me kai was
in the club this weekend do you know
where manchin was this weekend tell us
meeting with biden they're doing a
little vacay together okay okay a little
bit i wonder why though i wonder why
biden wants a mansion's vote that's
pretty obvious and he's and he's look do
you know how long manchin and biden have
known each other sure freaking 40 years
okay he's and this is what i've come how
long ago did i tell you keep your eye
out for this guy joe manchin
three years ago almost you've been
saying it for a while yeah you
introduced me to manchester united and
just because i used to watch him on
morning joe on msnbc at the height of
the trump stuff when it was so easy for
a democrat to talk [ __ ] about trump he
goes look
i'm not going to talk trash about the
president he just held himself so
honorably i said
this guy's who what's this guy's deal
and i looked into him a little bit he's
a democrat in the reddest state in the
country
understand the the his constituents
versus um his party and his allegiance
he's a guy who does what he feel is
right and and takes care of his people
he's been he's been a democrat for 40
plus years you think he's going to
switch over a little hot water right now
i don't think he's going anywhere i
think even if he goes dependent
independent he's going to caucus with
the democrats he understands how
valuable his vote is at this point and
he's going to play his card and he's
going to play it well you've seen that
this three and a half trillion dollar
infrastructure deal has now somehow gone
to one and a half trillion just because
he said that's what i'm going for
every sentence he says is worth like a
hundred
million dollars well don't forget about
kristen cinema as well that's true but
um
she's a little more of a wild guard than
him but
he's a g he's a g and i i don't
is the whole point that you think he's
going to leave the democratic party
or i think he's going to leave yeah no i
think the meeting with biden is okay so
let's actually process this yes what
happens if he says i'm leaving and it
goes independent is it a black eye
is it a story yes of course it's just
tell me why it's a black guy well he's
the number one senator in the news right
now i don't think that's saying hey look
i don't like why is that a big deal is
that a bad look for biden yes how is it
a bad look for biden because it's
somebody leaving the democratic party so
let's go what is the media gonna spin it
what's the media gonna say you're gonna
say he's over it or he's trying to
become like because he is the roadblock
now that's stopping all this so that
would make it more sense now the
democrats unified and he's now
the rogue democrats you know you know
how some of these uh superstars when
they get a divorce with their husband
they'll have somebody on the media spill
a story saying the fact that the husband
was cheating right and all along maybe
it was the other one okay i mean this
happens all the time right so they're
going to go to the pr guy and what is
the story that they're all going to be
on the same page with if mansion leaves
he's a traitor
i don't think they're going to take that
position
i think they're going to take it more as
you know uh
you know this guy's never been a
democrat
he's never he's been a closet republican
yeah this has been coming for a long
time and he has lost his touch with the
people you know he they're gonna spin
he's getting old he's getting they're
going to make something about that
perform i don't think it's going to be
that big of a deal if he leaves or not
by the way no i think he's a little bit
of a black guy one week two weeks gone
and he's done well i think for him
though he he wields more power within
the democratic party i actually agree
with him so if his whole thing is safe
in america and i want to be i
want to be able to influence my fellow
democrats it's way stronger to stay in
no question about it as opposed to and
by the way it's like how a lot of people
like every like the birthday party when
people were over a lot of the friends
that were here from florida guess what
they're all saying when the conversation
comes up about desantis and trump guess
what they say i hope desantis doesn't
run no nobody in florida
wants to send not nobody let me restate
most of the people who live in florida
don't want this guy to run because
they're worried who's going to replace
him they're going to stay governor
florida we want him to stay
who will replace him that's a good point
that's the biggest concern so they do
not want him to run for president by the
way the democrats would be absolute
fools to talk any trash about joe
manchin let's say they do something to
piss him off and he doesn't want to run
for re-election again you know who gets
voted in right there
a hundred percent of republican senator
they flip the scene okay they flip that
like if if i'm joe biden and if i'm the
dnc i'm doing everything to make sure
joe manchin's having a wonderful
freaking day today
by the way and i don't even even if he
leaves the party and becomes an
independent
do you know there's two senators that
are independent that caucus with the
democrats right now
if he does in the party who are the two
senators
freaking bernie
independent he's a democrat though and
then angus king from maine
there's two independents already that
caucus with democrats so i think this is
just nonsense i i don't think mansion's
going anywhere i think at the end of the
day they got to get a deal done and
they're going to do the reconciliation
package whatever that is where you have
50 votes and kamala is going to
um you know bump it over and they just
got to work on
mansion which they're currently working
on and then you get this girl's
sentiment i i think it's a bigger deal
than that i think it's it's exactly
descriptive of the infighting within the
party are they going to go the aoc
rashida talib ilhan omar bernie route
are they going to go the joe manchin
moderate christian cinema route i mean i
think it's so what happens
if
when when the jail mansions are out and
you've got the new blood where does the
democratic party go and i think this is
illustrative of that and they're
fighting for the face of the percentage
of the democrats do you think are
rashida talib type people aoc i don't
think what percentage i don't think it's
a big percentage i think it's maybe 20
but they're the last 15 they're the
loudest correct you're right they're to
just drag everything more that direction
right exactly i mean kamala harris was
the farthest left senator in the senate
before she got elected she was even
farther left than bernie sanders was and
i think this is illustrative of the in
far fighting within the party
by the way people are commenting all
this stuff you know pbd for governor all
this stuff the one thing that i will say
is which i appreciate but i will say the
one that says francis suarez would
replace desantis as a governor he would
be very interested yes if he ran by the
way yes but
i wouldn't run for president if i'm
desantis if i'm not certain that suarez
is not going to run
if suarez is not running governor i'm
not sure if i want him running for by
the way you i mean you've met francis
soros
interviewed him a few times absolute
stud
republican you know he said um
he gave a speech he spoke like
low taxes low regulation he said um
he goes something to the effect of um
when you're a mayor
you know you don't it doesn't matter if
you're republican or democrat you just
want to get [ __ ] done in your community
and that's the power of being a mayor he
said there's there's
talked about just being independent and
he's killing it in miami right now he's
making national waves he's a young stud
he's probably in his
mid 40s at the oldest
he just watch out for him he's going to
make great francis suarez i mean listen
if not him maybe jorge has vidal who
knows they say something to me and knock
their asses out can you imagine what did
you say
democratic governor knocked out by jorge
masvidal jorge masvadal is asked to
remove from the election however he is
by far the most popular candidate ever
to run for the state of florida i think
uh usman would have something to say to
him about that i can see you reading
that story pat alright let's read the
story that's a satire by the way
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]